Beans were hot.
Somehow I got later
it up and flick the juice on
mostly.
So come over and
be, need to be.
They were all day, all day still bubbling.
When I pulled my,
when was this?
It went, I, oh yeah. Nothing on
my skin is,
can you get off?
Get, I thought it was too,
my team kind.
I lost one because he's in the military.
I another guy.
Tomorrow I'll see if I can find
out text.
Good evening. Good evening. Are you guys blessed? Good.
Good. Everybody have a good day.
I, I don't know about you guys,
but, um, one of the things that I feel
whenever I come running this room on Wednesday night is
I feel like my day has been full packed
and I'm rushing to dinner and I'm rushing into this room,
and I'm not quite getting to the point of
peace where I can actually enjoy
and appreciate God and what he's got.
So, as we start, I don't know how you guys unwind.
I don't, I don't know how you do it.
I used to, uh, have these jobs that I'd get to work, uh,
and I, my commute would be like 45 minutes to the job, used
to lived in North Edmond, worked in El Reno, if
that gives you any indication, right?
One of the things that I loved about that was
it gave me time to gear up in the morning,
and it gave me time to wind down in the evening.
And I got to spend time, quiet.
Time on the way, quiet time on back. Come
Back.
This isn't 45 minutes,
but I'd like to take a couple minutes to pray
as we start time so that we can get our minds
and hearts calm.
Go free. Well, God, thank you for today.
Uh, thank you that each one of us
and woke up this morning with breath in our lungs, father
with energy and to roll out of bed, uh, father with a,
an outlook on the things that we would be engaged in
and, uh, do.
If Father, I know that all those plans,
if everybody in this room is like me, none
of those plans always turn out the way that we want.
Our days get crazy and we get hectic
and, uh, father, we lose track of all of the plans
that we had, and we do the things that, uh,
oftentimes become urgent
and we end up kind of getting just run through life.
And I don't want that to be our time here tonight.
Just pray that you would, so our minds
and our hearts should remove the distractions of the day
that you would allow us to enter into your presence,
and that we might come to know you.
That is our desire. It's in.
Okay? So how'd you guys get here?
Back seat in my son's spot.
Not really the question,
Why are You here?
Why
Glorify God that
that's the answer, right?
I mean, that's certainly the answer we wanting.
That's, that's the answer I want from all
of our Bible students and everything.
Um, oftentimes we really have to reflect on that question
and the answer multiple times in a day,
not just when we're in this room, right?
Why am I here? How did I get here?
So tonight, as we think about and talk about,
and I want this to be dialogue, okay?
As we think about, talk about the doctrine command, I want,
I want us to think and talk about two things
and really only two things.
The first is our origin,
and the second is our purpose.
Okay? How did I get here?
And what am I doing here now that I'm here, right?
So as we,
as we think about those things, how did we get here?
What is our order here?
My mom's name's Beverly and my dad's name's Robert.
You know, we could talk about birds and bees
and all that kind of stuff, but
that's not really what I'm getting at.
How did we get here?
By the word of God speaking in the sin existence,
created side of the work of the dirt, the word of God
speaking us into existence.
The scriptures in Genesis chapter one begin with this,
this concept, this term next to Hilo, out
of nothing,
something God created.
All that was created out of nothing.
So let's turn Genesis chapter one.
Sure. At some point in time, all of us have, uh,
learned and memorized.
Day one, day two, day three, day four, day five, day six.
Right? And then day seven, what happens on day seven?
Rest rested, right? Okay.
If you think about though day one through six,
what was it that God created in those days?
I don't need a, just think about
all the things that God created.
Give, give some examples, man.
Energy and line,
Space.
Say that again. Space. Space, okay.
Seasons, plants.
Okay, with the planets came the sun
and the moon and the stars and all of what we see.
What about before the plan and
before the sun, like light and darkness.
Time, time began right at this point.
What else? John plays all things.
The ocean. The what?
The book of John says he created all things, all things.
He did. The ocean.
What about what's in the ocean? All those things.
Anybody at diver here? Yeah, man. Love it.
I mean, really love being under the water.
That's pretty sweet. If you haven't been under the
water, you have no idea.
The magical things that got.
What about the things on the land,
Air, water, All those, all the animals.
All the current, you guys, you go
to the zoo, you've been to the zoo, right?
Yeah. What's your favorite zoo animal?
All All of them. Pit boat.
Actually mine or the is
Mine.
All the birds in the air.
I mean, can you think of some magnificent things
that God created out of?
Nothing. Something God created.
Can you think of magnificent things? Spider.
Spider things will happen. Yeah,
Because The spiders created, the cop has created, made.
Spider. Spider. Just do it.
Spiders. Just do it.
Or just a baby think.
I don't know how you could deny God and look at a baby.
Yeah. Yeah.
One of the greatest experiences
of my life is watching my children be born.
Probably the greatest experience
of my life is watching my children.
Something I could dare do.
Watching someone else's children be born.
Like that's disgusting.
On the other hand, like that's special,
but all of those things that God created,
we could read all of the verses
and see how he created the birds in the air
and the fish in the sea and all of these things.
God saved what scripture tells us is the best for last.
And what was that?
Yeah. So
how do we get here? We're
Creative.
We were created by a God who is highly
creative, very particular.
We were created by a God who had a
magnificent design that is so intricate
and detailed that whether you believe
that the earth is young at 6,000 years,
or you believe that the earth is old at 6 million years,
mankind still has not identified
and understood all of its workings.
That is the God that created us.
So as mankind being created,
we have to ask another question.
Why? Why would God have created us?
What are some of the things that, that the world might say?
What are some of the arguments that the world might give?
Someone needed to tend to the soil.
Someone needed to tend to this way. Okay?
He, he actually gave man a responsibility
to do this right when you put him in the garden.
Okay,
I heard that one.
Okay. A another need.
So we've got a need here and a need here. Lonely. Okay?
Why else? I read the word regents,
which is a fancy word,
but basically we're here to help carry out his glory
and his order as in his lightness.
Okay? Everything that he's made, he wants us
to care and represent that.
His love for his creation. Yeah.
And we're his ambassadors or regions? Yeah.
I mean they use the word regions. Yeah.
So for sure, for sure.
Listen, let's think about those things though.
All of those things we just kind of came up with
that weren't like these really specific, uh, biblical
concepts, right?
All of these have some concept in them that God somehow
had a need for man,
that there was a need to cultivate the soils
and need for companionship.
There was a need for fulfilling some thing,
right? Is that true?
No. No.
Why? He
Doesn't need anything.
Like, God doesn't need it because he wants it.
He did it because he wants, it ought to be fun
For sure. He did it because
he has got a love
and that love that he shows.
The father shows the son and he reflects it back to it.
He does that again
because he is a gift God that loves and he gives.
So he created a being like that
To display his glory.
I want you to think about this, this concept of need,
though a little bit further, right?
God has an incommunicable
and, sorry, I'm gonna start on that.
An incommunicable attribute that he is
independent of all things.
Mm-hmm. Yeah. Right? Okay.
God doesn't need anything.
The scriptures actually tell us that he's self existent.
The scriptures tell us that he was not lonely.
Look at John 17, five.
Somebody pull that up for me real quick.
Somebody else. Look up John 1724.
So somebody get verse five, somebody get verse 24,
And Now Father glorify me in your own presence
with the glory that I had with you before the world existed.
That's Jesus talking.
So if we had a printed Bible,
that'd be in red letters, right?
Mm-hmm. That, that red letter tells us
that Jesus was saying, Lord, when I was with you,
we had this communion together,
we have perfect relationship.
Does that sound like a God who is needy of relationship?
No. What about verse 24?
Jesus speaking to the Father, father, I desire that
they also, who you have given me be with me where I am,
so that they may see my glory, which you have given me
for you loved me before the foundations,
the foundation of the Lord.
Yeah. Love.
Has anybody in here ever
been loved?
That's really brilliant. Sit. Yes.
Okay. If, if you have been loved,
do you know, can you be alone?
Can you be needing companionship when you are in
that relationship?
No. Yeah.
The, the need is completely fulfilled.
But even more so than this, God
didn't need it anyway.
It's very difficult to understand
that he would have been complete
and perfect had any of that not ever existed.
Okay? So he doesn't have a need.
He's not lonely in that way.
How about is he lacking something
that may only man can provide?
We, we've talked over here just in a negotiation that,
you know, maybe man might have been created,
the world might say to cultivate things.
Is there some need that only man could fulfill?
No, there's nothing like that.
How about is there, um, did God lack longevity?
Meaning God needed offspring
to perpetuate some name,
or God needed offspring to perpetuate some, you know,
lifestyle or something like that?
Did God need that?
No, Because he's eternal, right?
So
He Didn't need in that way.
I'm gonna challenge those concepts a little bit different
way as well.
Okay? We know God to be eternal.
If I know God's eternal
and I know that God is unchanging.
Okay? Now, those two things, eternal and unchanging.
If I suppose that God is need
in some way, how long is God
going to be needy?
He's eternal forever. If he's, if he's eternal
and he's unchanging, he's unchangeable,
he will be needy forever.
Okay? Why would a God,
why would anybody create mankind
that is temporary
and flawed to fill a need that they cannot fill
in a temporary way when the need is permanent?
That doesn't make any sense at all.
God didn't need us to create us.
God created us for a purpose, though.
So then why did God create us?
Anybody? We have an answer.
Could we go look maybe in that point of creation?
Let's go back to Genesis chapter one.
You guys were there just a minute ago.
Look in verse start in verse 26.
Let's read through verse 29.
Yes, Genesis one verses 26
through 29, Is what He,
what Moses writes, then God said,
let us make man in our image after our likeness,
and let them have dominion over the fish of the sea
and over the birds of the heavens and over the livestock,
and over all the earth
and over every creeping thing that creeps on the earth.
So God created man in his own image, in the image
of God, he created him, male and female, he created them,
and God bless them.
And God said to them, be fruitful and multiply
and fill the earth and sub do it,
and have dominion over the fish of the sea
and over the birds of the heavens,
and over every living thing that moves on the earth.
And God said, behold,
I have given you every plant yielding seed
that is on the face of all the earth
and every tree with seed in its fruit.
You shall have them for food.
Why does it say that we were created
dominion.
Okay. Dominion to have rule over the earth
and the things that end the earth.
Okay? We, we care for his creation. Okay?
It's part of the dominion, part of dominion.
It's part of that caring for what he created, for sure.
And you know, you're reflecting that love that he has
for his creation, right? So,
Well 'cause we was
made in his reflection, his image.
Now he's, and he did that. He created us in his image.
And so now as we create things multiply upon the earth,
we are increasing his image.
We are to bury his image and that multiply upon the earth.
That is why, okay. Or his glo through that.
Okay? Did you guys ca catch that?
There's, there's a, a specific, uh,
guidance here on what we're supposed to do
that is fundamental to what David just shared.
It's in this passage. What does it say?
It says, we are to be something.
His image, Not his image.
Dan. Fruitful. Fruitful.
We are to be fruitful and multiply. Right?
We're to procreate later in scripture.
God tells the people to fill the earth.
We're getting close. We're not there yet. Right?
Fill the earth. It's perforate.
God doesn't just want us to procreate though.
We, we know this because in Deuteronomy chapter six,
when we look in Deuteronomy chapter six,
it tells us exactly, not only are we procreate,
but we are to train into our children
and teach our offspring
and raise them up in the ways of the Lord.
That is really the multiplication of that,
that God requires of us.
When we look at Genesis chapter one, it is not enough
that we should just simply create children.
There's a purpose for those children to bear the image
of God in the same way that we're designed.
Okay? What else is in there?
Oh, You keep saying
that God made everything that was good.
In fact, it was very good.
And I wasn't joking earlier when I said he did it
because he had, it was too fun to do.
Yeah. And I was inspired by that
'cause of Revelation four, which says that worthy of Lord
to receive glory and honor
and power without his created all things
and for thy pleasure, they are and were created.
He was pleased to do it.
And so when we live out the purposes that he designed us
to do that for now, that's one
of the ways that we please him.
Let's flip that. What did just said,
how many parents in the room?
Hands. Hands. That's awesome. Parents are the room.
Have your children ever not done what you asked them to do?
Double hands, double hands and thumb. Yeah.
We don't need, we don't even need names.
This current or past? Current or past.
Have your children ever blatantly disobeyed
what you told them to do?
Have your children ever naively not done something
that you expected them to do?
In those, in all of those examples
and all of those cases were, what was your,
uh, receipt from that?
How did you feel about that?
Did you feel
honored, respected?
Did you feel that you were loved and cherished?
Think about how God must feel
with the sin that man
Came with, right?
We just see it in a fraction.
God goes so much deeper into us,
but yet we're designed to do all these things.
You guys missed one by the way.
Like we really need to look at this one.
It, it's really important. It is actually in first 29.
At the very end. It says, you shall have them for food.
So God created us to do the most Baptist thing
to ever be done, which is to eat.
And if you want proof, all we have
to do is walk down the hall, right?
Maybe Trevor, yes.
I think the be fruitful multiply is,
I don't think we wait to read that
to say, oh, you know what?
Maybe kids are being a good thing.
It seems more like,
without even thinking too hard about it, couples who
aren't kids think more
or less unselfishly that they want to share their love with,
with that person that they're gonna bring to the world.
So that's a good thing. 'cause if we really thought
logically, we might say, well,
it's gonna cost a lot of money.
It might not bring me joy all the time.
So maybe, maybe not
certainly an act of obedience,
but also an act of blessing from the work, right?
Um, I think it also has something to do with like,
like a spiritual mentorship for other people.
Like I think like if I don't have kids right now,
I could still obey it and like disciple someone or something
and leave them spiritually.
And that would be like me multiplying
Our people. Yeah.
Which is very cool.
So if we, if we were to kind of take a detour,
I would detour us to Galatians chapter five and chapter six,
and Galatians chapter five, what we're told
by Paul is we're told that we have a responsibility
to bear our own burdens and to actually grow in the Lord.
And then he turns right around chapter six
and he says, well, you know what?
You're also responsible to bear one another's burdens
in that same way.
And I think that's absolutely the case we're talking about
that it's a great, uh, great context we might go to,
to talk about, uh, mentoring and meeting one another.
Um, so in this,
we find our purpose to glorify God.
We talked about, to enjoy him and delighting him.
Last week, Steve shared, uh,
one comment on his notes on the first page, if you guys saw
that, uh, was that the chief end of man is to
glorify God and enjoy him forever.
Him, right? We see a lot of, uh,
glorifying God, enjoying
and delighting in him those just as equally as important.
Look at Romans five.
Romans five is sergeant verse one.
Paul writes, therefore, since we have been justified
by faith, we have peace with God
through our Lord Jesus Christ.
Through him, we have also obtained access by faith
and the disgrace in which we stand.
And we rejoice in hope of the glory of God.
Not only that, but we rejoice on our sufferings knowing
that suffering produces endurance
and endurance produces character.
A character produces hope.
And hope does not put us to shame
because God's love has been poured into our hearts,
through the Holy Spirit who has been given to us.
We're rejoice in the hope of God.
Look, look also at one Thessalonians chapter five
star in verse 16 through 18.
Rejoice always pray without ceasing.
Give thanks in all circumstances for this is the will of God
and Christ Jesus for you,
rejoice always to rejoice in him.
Look, these, these go together
because we're praying without ceasing.
Who is it that we bring to?
We give thanks in all circumstances.
Who is it that we give thanks to?
We give thanks to the one that is in control of
and command all things.
And from whose hand, all good things come
Right.
Lastly, one Peter, turn over.
First Peter chapter one,
verse eight and nine.
Though you have not seen him, you love him,
though you do not now see him, you believe in him
and rejoice with joy that is inexpressible
and filled with glory, obtaining the of your faith,
the salvation of your souls.
We have a purpose.
If someone asks you the question, why are you here?
Don't think about the tactical.
Think about this strategically, think about the purpose.
Think about why am I really here?
When you're walking down the odds of Walmart,
why am I really here?
There's a person you're passing here
and there's a person I'm passing here
and there's a person I'm gonna talk to at the,
at the counter when I check out.
Maybe sometimes because times we like fly through
that self checkout thing, right?
Think about that. I
I think it's, it's really interesting.
This next question I've got is what does it really mean?
This to be made in the image of God,
to bear this image?
What does that mean when I don't know how many
of you guys are actually like, have a book and read book
and all that, or just come to
the time we have together.
But in the particular chapter here
on the origin man, um,
Gruten goes into some great detail
and builds an argument around why we really don't need to,
you know, be very specific about what it means
to be in the image of God.
That all these scholars have gone to this great, uh, pains
and, you know, built great arguments for it and everything.
And Gruder says that it is essentially
for us to pour into the word
and everything we come to know about gout is
what that is the image of gout.
All the things that we can think about.
But yet there's some things that we might say, man,
may not have gotten for God.
But let's talk for a minute about
what this means.
Um, page 2 36.
In the, in the book says this, groom writes,
the text only needs to affirm that man is like God.
And the rest of scripture fills in more details
to explain this.
In fact, as we read the rest of scripture, we realize
that a full understanding of man's likeness
to God would require a full understanding of who God is
in his being and in his actions,
and a full understanding of who man is
and what he does.
I love this. He's spot on
our community group in college
and young adults, uh, about,
it's probably been about a year ago now, we actually, uh,
went through a systematic theology that happens
to be all of the questions
that we ask our deacons to fill out
from a doctrinal perspective so
that we can ensure from a church
that they are doctrinally aligned with us.
And I, I did a little experiment with everyone
because those questions are put in a,
in a particular order, okay?
They're not just randomly 40 to semi questions.
They're put in a particular order.
And I asked everybody when we started,
you know, we did a, a summary.
We, we went through and said why we're doing this?
And we talked about kind of opening it up,
handed out all the 40 questions to everybody.
And I said, Hey. I said, where would you guys like to start?
Where do you want to begin?
Any guesses where everybody wanted to begin?
30 to 40 we're pretty far down the list.
We were like smack dab in the middle somewhere.
And it was actually, we started out
and it had to do with the doctrine of sin.
Man, I tell you what, like God couldn't have set this thing
up any better, right?
Because we got right into the doctrine of sin
and we were starting to talk about it.
And in order to understand
and talk about the doctrine of sin, in order
to grasp it at all, you have to grasp
and you have understand that there is a holy God
that is completely perfect in all of his attributes.
Because sin is anything that contradicts
what those attributes are.
We have to understand the doctrine of God first.
What drew him saying here is absolutely the same thing
for the doctrine of man.
In order for us to understand the doctrine of man
and our purpose, our ability to actually reflect the
likeness and the being
and the image of him in this world, we have
to understand God.
It is the fundamental for everything
that we do.
Just to understand.
So back to the question.
In what ways do we
share this image of God?
United Word. Okay? Kindness is an attribute of God.
Our kindness is one.
Relational, Relational. Explain that.
How we love others through kindness, how we respect them,
how we love them, and knows our family.
Whoever that everyone, yeah,
Family, neighbors.
He created his head's why he made that.
That was the whole reason he made, had eve,
took Eve from Adam's side, is so
that they could have the relationship.
He wasn't made just to be a single person human as
for a relationship.
We, we hadn't talked about that.
So Genesis chapter one tells us this general
creation, Genesis chapter two tells us specific account of
that creation with daily leadership referring to, yeah.
How about physically?
No. No. Why not
God's spirit.
God is spirit, which is another act.
John 4 22.
Absolutely. Well, when God appeared to Abraham,
he also had a human, Peter.
That's right, that's right.
When God appeared to Abraham,
God appeared in several different times in the
Old Testament before, right?
We know those to be theos
and those thes are all time periods when we believe
that Jesus is the one that appeared with Adam
and in representation of God.
Absolutely. But David,
to your point, John, uh, 4 24 does tell us
that God is spirit.
John one 18 says
that no one has seen God.
Right? You remember when Moses was in the,
sorry, David was in the cliff, right?
He's wanting to see God got passes by God says,
you gotta turn your back and just the wind goes right.
Another example of that God is invisible.
Colossians one 15.
So when we look at ourselves in the image of God, I think
From a mankind
Perspective, we oftentimes think about
y'all must have arms and legs and fingers and toes. No.
Doesn't. When you can, you assume
that spirit doesn't have a form ness.
What about you remember donkey, the be
he was rid on the donkey, donkey saw, end with this word
saw bigger of the spirit,
Right? So
you not, you cannot assume
that also spirit could have form kind of form.
Yeah,
We're for angels, we're told all kinds
of things about their design, right?
I mean, they have crazy number of wings
and they have, you know, these very scary types of images
that are described in scripture.
So, um, that's,
that's not when we're talking about God though,
God has taken on his spirit home. Right?
I was gonna say, try to lead off of that, to try
and give like a better visual example is like when you're
talking about the image of God,
we're not specifically talking about something physical
because then you can apply that to anyone.
So it's like, if you think God is a physical being like
Jesus than like people who are women or have no arms
or born this way, that doesn't mean they're any
less of an individual God.
So like, yes, God is physical as in Jesus,
But good point.
That's not the thing. Trevor.
I think one thing that is interesting for me to think about
is that our bodies do speak about God.
Like we have ears and God ears, we have mouths
and God speaks, we have eyes
and God sees, you know what I mean?
Like there are things about our bodies that
reflect the nature of God,
but not in like a physical form, not a physical
Field. Yeah.
And especially like you're talking about the triune
in his fullness
because you, we would say the top of sun, uh,
pre carbonate sun seemed assume form
certainly took on flesh.
So, so God in Christ now has a body, right?
But that's different than, yeah.
Good points. One More. I have one
More. Yeah, one more.
Uh, what I say, we are man is created an energy.
God, if we were to also consider how
human kind is separate from all their creative beings, uh,
I would say that we have a six, we have hope,
dreams, we can plan.
We love all their creative beings do not have
that conscience
Consciousness that, so in, in addition
to relational, you hit nail on the head.
There's kind of three other moral, spiritual, and mental.
We morally have these guides
that we know to be true, right?
To follow, um, spiritual aspects as well.
Mental aspects, the ability to think and collegiate.
We as human beings are able to,
and have continued to make things more complicated, right?
We, we share in the attribute
that God perfectly displayed in creation.
We create oftentimes, unfortunately, our own turmoil
we share in those things.
So how do you feel like man's doing
in fulfilling this purpose
with the people I run with?
Okay, the church is like Lebanon alone.
Yeah. Over time, I think about today compared
to 4,000 years ago,
and I'm encouraged time horizon
human kind is multiplying is the fruitfulness
that's individual.
The actual disc point of God's image, right
through the multiplication Absolutely.
Question. These are, these are things that we're,
we're not gonna get into any detail with time, right?
So over the next couple weeks, as we continue
to talk about document manage what's coming up in two weeks,
I think from now month, um, couple weeks from now,
we'll talk more about those things.
You're absolutely right. We don't know.
We, well, first of all,
we know from scripture multiple places, right?
Man does not seek after God.
So if God's image is so important, if us knowing him is
so important to us, reflecting the image that he, uh,
put into us to display, then we should
seek after God.
Because the only way we're going to be able to do that is
to know who he is, right?
To understand.
We can't exhaust our knowledge
and understanding in the side.
Those Ians 13, the end of the very end
of the chapter tells us what tells us.
We are known. In part we,
we know in part, but we are known fully.
And when we see him, we will know him
as he knows us, right?
So when we think about the whole process of our salvation,
we can start with justification
and we can go through sanctification and sanctification.
Just think of it simply as a continuous process of
confession, repentance, confession, repentance over
and over and over again.
Until we are becoming like,
but we'll not be like until are
glorified in his presence.
When we'll know him fully, then we'll be like him.
Okay? Back into that.
So den talks about one other thing, I'm going to just kind
of, uh, close on this bit of conversation.
We only have a few minutes left.
Um, here talks about one other thing, um,
and that is this image.
He talks about it in terms of being
damaged, not destroyed.
So what did you say?
True? Who says truth?
I said damaged, not destroyed. How so?
Well, it even says that
after the fall in three, in five, one and nine, six
and Genesis, it states that the real well, nine, six,
it states that they can't commit murder.
Not to commit murder because we are man is
made in the image of God.
Stewart's still, were still buried after the fall.
That image you got even
in, forgot the verse.
But in the New Testament talking about,
I think it's James three nine Target, we're not
to cursing another person
because they are made into gun, not to spark.
Talk about, about not to do harm to, yeah.
What perspectives should that give us of how we engage
and treat and interact with others that are not
Do what
I, we would treat one another with this respect
And Attention.
We wouldn't, we would treat one another that way.
Why should we treat any of other, any of God's other created
About
Potentially greater care?
David Saying you treat
Potentially greater care.
He said potentially greater care for those
that are not yet.
Because our aim is what reconciliation.
Our aim is rec reconciliation, not
with us, no reconciliation.
We've got ministry of reconciliation,
ministry of reconciliation.
Our aim is to display the of God
before our aim is to, is for them to then
display the image of God that they were created in, right?
Yes. Over and over and
Over again.
So man,
that so that we might bring
our obedience in our
procreation, our obedience in teaching
and training our children and others around us.
Our obedience in making disciples
is of the utmost importance to us.
That's main and purpose.
Um, Jackson is gonna come up
and share for a few minutes.
All right, uh, my name's Jackson.
If I had the pleasure of meeting y'all.
Um, I serve here at Henderson as,
or I work in our college ministry, young adults.
Um, so if you're interested in born in any
college students here, let know.
Um, but In our time
of discussion, I kind of wanna model something
after what we do in college ministry every Sunday, uh, right
during the first service, uh,
we have a thing called table talks.
So there's this little discussion,
or sorry, a little teaching, um, that falls by discussion
and a little teaching discussion,
a little teaching discussion.
And I've found that so much more impactful in my life than
carrying what I've learned into my day to day.
And so that's kind of what I want to do for us.
I'm gonna ask you to do something a little bit uncomfortable
and talk to those around you.
Um, so I've prepared five questions, um, to kind
of help lead that time, lead that discussion for you.
Um, you by no means have to go off of these, I don't want
to limit you in any way,
but if you like, shoot, I don't know where to start.
This is what this is for. I'll try to find up here.
But, um, Paul, I love this idea
of being created in the image of God.
I think it's something super practical
that we can take in our day to day lives.
So a couple questions, stuff to think about.
Talk about Is, do your commitments
and goals align with God's purpose for your life?
Does this idea, does learning that you were created
for God's glory, does that change the way you view your life
or how you're using your life right now?
How do you represent God's character in your everyday life?
What are you currently doing right now
that showcases God's care to God's attributes?
How do you know and enjoy God personally?
Is that something you're doing right now?
And in what ways are you doing that?
Trevor kind of talked about this earlier, but how,
or sorry, how does being made in the image
of God change the way you view others?
We talked about a little bit already.
How does that change the way you view unbelievers?
And then lastly, I think Mark into this question as well, is
what does the creation of man
the reveal about God's character, what does
that teach you about who God means?
So let's take a couple moments, maybe groups
of three to four.
I'll come back up here and we'll talk about it.
There's
One,
you join us
so dark.
Are you enjoying? Do you
go anywhere?
I mean, what
being in like in it
with him, looking for it.
Listen,
looking for how he,
I hate to interrupt any conversations.
Always my least favorite part on Sundays.
Okay, there's a lot.
Before I hand Things over to Mark really quick,
I just am curious, I want to hear from maybe a couple
Different people, um, kind of
what your group talked about.
What discussed, what were some common things
That might have Popped up?
Oh, share.
I think on the goals, I don't think we all have the same
goals, have some goals.
I I just don't think we at all
agree on what, what they are
About
the general lecture of these questions about, you know,
us sharing our likeness with the world.
You know, we say this church often
that we love God and we love the people.
When we got into discussion about in this world,
it staying the sin
and a lot of the world doesn't follow God's eternal plan.
Uh, as, as Christians, how do we reflect that in a world
that has rules sometimes of completely talent to God
and you know, sometimes can get in trouble, uh,
in workplace, uh, we just talked about
how we have opportunities to do that at times, uh,
and still respect everybody's, uh,
walk, whatever that may be.
And I said, well, what I do is I teach.
So when I get up
and introduce myself, we all introduce ourselves
to each other as a class, is
to just share what's important to me.
And it's really kind of invitation to what it kids,
I share them what's important to me.
There's an invitation disguised it matter. So
That's kind of one Aspect.
All this,
Knowing God personally
and spending time with him helps line the other things up,
helps us, reflect us in together,
and it aligns our desires more.
We talked about reflecting an image bearing
and something that Mt.
Wright wrote about, um, was just imagining ourselves
as a mirror, but instead of a mirror hanging on the wall,
think of it as a pitched at 45 degrees.
So God's image reflects on us out in the world.
So we reflect his character, his love, his racist mercy,
his truth, and everything else like that 45 degree angle.
And then vice versa. It's a two-way street.
We reflect back to God, praise, adoration,
thanksgiving and glory.
And so that reflection is running both directions off
that mirror visually.
We want be diligent to, with the spirit's help keep
that mirror a good reflection.
So when it's staying with sin, let's confess it
and clean that up and,
and try to be that, uh, with the spirit's,
help that reflection out.
That's a good mark.
That's all I job.
Excuse me while I check Facebook.
Just kidding. Yeah. Thanks guys. That was great. Um,
so, um, you know, I've been looking ahead
for the class next semester. Hey, you can do the
Bathroom here.
We, y'all want to try,
Well it project to the bathroom, I guess.
Anyway, I'm out of time.
Um, so looking ahead to the class next semester,
we've got systematic part two.
Part of what we'll do is the doctrine of salvation.
And so in that we're talking about how God
rescues us in Christ from our broken,
fallen image, right?
Our simple nature. We are rescued by God in spite of that.
But then a part of it, a part of that is understanding.
Uh, what we'll also study then is the idea
of sanctification.
That is the idea of the work of God
and his grace in our lives by the power of the Holy Spirit
changing us to make us more like what?
More like I'm open
to suggestions what Christ.
Christ, right? Who, who is the image of God?
And so the idea of God's work of grace in our lives is he,
he's making us more and more like the original imageable.
We won't meet that in this life fully, you know?
But there is a process of,
of restoring the ruins, if you will.
And so, but the idea that Christ being that the perfect man,
the perfect image
of God we're made in the image and likeness of God.
But the Bible says that the Lord Jesus was made that he,
he is you wanna make, he is the image of God, right?
And, uh, so anyway, as I was thinking about these things
and I was thinking about a song that we might sing together
to conclude, I I really couldn't find a good one
that has sang about the image of God in man.
But I thought the whole point of the image of God in man
and mankind is, is that it reflects the goodness
and the glory and the greatness of God.
So, uh, I just want to sing this song.
I don't know if you would all know it.
Uh, it's by Fernando Ortega. It's, um, our great God.
Sure. So let's, uh, you would stand
and together
And
our,
And Rock
and
All,
All right.
You may be dismissed and you are upset
Every time.